Traduttore: Lara Carabelli
Revisore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Non ho sentito la mia presentazione prima
non so se ha detto cose giuste
io spero di si,
dopo cercherò di sentire.
Allora
Buongiorno a tutti!
Io mi chiamo Federico Baglioni
sono milanese trapiantato a Roma
e sono un biotecnologo.
Quindi principalmente come biotecnologo,
la mia aspirazione, qualche anno fa,
era quella di fare ricerca.
Ad un certo punto,
per una serie di motivi,
ho deciso di cambiare, sono diventato
un divulgatore scientifico.
Come mai un divulgatore scientifico?
Un po' perché forse l'ambiente
di laboratorio
non era esattamente il mio ambiente
poi mi piaceva parlare alle persone,
spiegare la scienza
spiegare quello che fanno i ricercatori.
Come mai? Perché la scienza
non è facile da capire.
Anzi, generalmente, ne capiamo
abbastanza poco.
E quindi vorrei parlare proprio
di questo
e andare un pochino più nel profondo.
Cioè, come mai facciamo fatica
a capire, per esempio, la scienza?
E facciamo un passo ancora indietro.
Tutto nasce nel nostro cervello.
Cioè il nostro cervello
fa delle cappellate. Sbaglia.
E ve lo faccio subito [capire]
partendo con un esempio.
In particolare, un test,
che è questo qui.
Cosa dovete fare?
Chi l'ha già visto: muti,
mi raccomando eh!
Cosa dovete fare?
Dovete contare il numero di passaggi
della squadra bianca.
Solo della squadra bianca.
Pronti?
(Siiii)
Ok, benissimo.
Ok.
Quanti passaggi?
(16 / 21)
21?
(Risate)
Come 21?
Ok. 16, 21. Altre proposte?
Chi offre di più?
15?
Allora, la risposta giusta,
ho controllato stanotte
perché non ero molto convinto,
sono 16.
Quanti hanno visto il gorilla?
Il gorilla, dice?
Questo qua è fuori di melone.
C'è un gorilla. Ok.
Non solo.
Però attenzione:
Chi è che l'aveva già visto?
Eh.. furboni. Ok.
Oltre al gorilla, sono successe
delle altre cose in realtà.
È sparita una persona.
Se ne è andata via dal palco.
E nel frattempo lo sfondo
ha cambiato colore.
Quanti avevano visto anche
queste due cose?
Una? Nessuno aveva visto
anche queste cose?
Molto poche.
Cos'è che è successo?
È successo che noi abbiamo
prestato attenzione a qualche cosa.
Chi alla palla, chi magari era
un po' distratto e ha iniziato a contare
poi ha perso il conto,
si è messo a guardare in giro
e ha visto il gorilla,
possibile anche quello.
Chi aveva già visto il gorilla era lì:
"ah, gli altri non sanno cosa ho visto io"
Si è messo a guardare in giro e
magari ha visto la persona
che è uscita e via dicendo.
A questo punto:
a cosa serve questo test?
Proprio a mandarvi un messaggio.
Cioè, il nostro cervello,
bello, affascinante,
tremendamente affascinante, complicato,
fa un sacco di cose belle, positive
però non è perfetto.
Siamo portati a pensare
che sia una macchina.
È tutto l'opposto.
Anche il nostro cervello sbaglia.
E in particolare, sbaglia quando?
Quando ci sono di mezzo le emozioni.
Quando c'è di mezzo il cuore.
Le emozioni sono una cosa che
ci pervade.
Siamo fatti per essere suggestionati.
Siamo fatti anche per emozionarci.
Che è una cosa bellissima,
però a volte non ci fa più ragionare.
Un esempio particolare
è quando si ha a che fare con la scienza.
Perché la scienza?
Perché la scienza è complicata,
e abbiamo questo dualismo:
vediamo i ricercatori da un lato
come irragiungibili
come delle persone magnifiche o
della specie di supereroi
che fanno cose strane nei laboratori;
dall'altra parte però abbiamo anche
un po' paura di loro.
Abbiamo paura di quello che
possono fare e della loro potenza.
E tutto questo crea un vero e proprio
cortocircuito.
In particolare, noi abbiamo quindi paura
un pochino della scienza.
Ve lo dimostro.
Questa è un'immagine di cosa c'è
nel milkshake alla mela del McDonald.
Allora io vi chiedo:
guardando questa immagine
prendereste mai un prodotto
del genere?
Qualcuno dice:
"Che me frega? L'ho sempre preso così,
non è che mi cambi molto."
O: "Se non lo prendevo prima,
non lo prendo neanche adesso"
Cos'è che vi spaventa?
è pieno di cose che...
Che cosa sono queste cose?
Boh!
Ve lo dico io cosa sono.
Sono dei composti di una qualsiasi mela.
Qualsiasi. L'ho inventato.
Io ho preso, sapendo cosa c'è
dentro la mela,
ci sono questi composti tanto brutti,
ho messo un'immagine nera,
nera fa sempre un po' paura,
incute timore.
Ho utilizzato un po' il simbolo
della multinazionale cattiva e via dicendo
e ho trasmesso un messaggio
di paura, associato a delle parole
che non conoscete,
che non conosco neanche io
e che tendenzialmente mi fanno paura.
Sia perché non le conosco,
sia perché sono parole chimiche.
Noi abbiamo una paura incredibile
della chimica.
A volte anche per motivi storici,
incidenti del passato.
In generale quando noi sentiamo
qualcosa legato alla chimica
diciamo "Boh, questa cosa sarà
una cosa dannosa".
A prescindere.
Si chiama proprio "chemofobia":
paura delle parole chimiche.
Questo è un altro esempio
che si può trovare su internet:
digitando si vede questo acido idrico
con queste caratteristiche brutte brutte.
Cioè: può causare ustioni;
erosioni del suolo; piogge acide;
presenti nei tumori;
ce le ha praticamente tutte.
L'acido idrico, DHMO,
sta per monossido di idrogeno.
Non so se vi ricordate
le lezioni di chimica.
"Monossido" vuol dire che c'è un ossigeno
"di idrogeno" vuol dire che
ci sono due idrogeni.
Due idrogeni e un ossigeno chiamasi anche?
Acqua. Ok. Perfetto.
Uno dice: "ma perché mi stai dicendo
questa cosa?"
Per due motivi:
uno perché qualcuno
ci ha fatto addirittura una petizione
per bloccare la molecola
e c'è qualcuno
che ha firmato inconsapevolmente.
Perché ha firmato?
Perché uno dovrebbe
firmare una cosa del genere?
Perché ci sono delle parole chiave.
Parole chiave che ci incutono timore.
Tumori, ustioni, piogge acide
sono gran parte dei problemi
della società che vediamo.
Quindi non ci interessa più sapere
esattamente di cosa si stia parlando.
Ci va bene bloccarla perché
è una cosa che va contro
le nostre paure. Ok?
In altre parole: il nostro cervello
è fatto per semplificare.
Deve essere tutto rosso nero,
bianco nero se siete juventini.
In generale vediamo delle associazioni
anche dove non ci sono.
Due eventi per noi sono legati tra loro,
perché ci sembra logico.
È quella la cosa incredibile:
che a noi sembra assolutamente logico.
E non è detto che sia così.
Vi faccio un esempio con un altro video.
Qui ci vuole l'audio.
(Musica)
Okei, allora, facciamo un po' il ripasso.
Cosa è successo?
L'avete capita vero? Si? Ok.
Allora, il bambino che cosa sta facendo?
Sta usando? No, non i superpoteri.
Ragazzi, la forza.
Le basi, eh!
La forza! Ok?
Sta usando la forza per accendere
la macchina. Ok?
Crede di usare la forza.
E questi qua sono i due eventi.
In realtà chi è che accende la macchina?
Il padre. Tutti convinti vero?
L'accende il padre.
Allora in questo caso abbiamo due eventi
che ci sembrano legati.
Al bambino sembra logico
che lui fa così e accende la macchina.
In realtà c'è un terzo evento
che è quello di causa.
Allora in questo caso è molto semplice.
Ma pensate quanto può essere complicato
quando si ha a che fare con la salute,
l'alimentazione, cure, malattie,
via dicendo.
Lì diventa molto complesso
ragionare in termini razionali
e vedere che magari
non ci sono relazioni tra due eventi,
ma magari c'è una terza causa.
Diventa veramente complicato.
Allora cosa possiamo imparare
un pochino da queste piccole cose?
Appunto: il nostro cervello
si fa ingannare.
Quindi dobbiamo un pochino
starci sempre attenti
perché noi veniamo spinti dalle emozioni
che sono una cosa che ci fanno fare
tante cose molto utili
e anche di sopravvivenza.
A volte però ci mettono nei guai.
Per cui ci fanno credere a cose
che non sono vere.
E la scienza ha un problema particolare
che purtroppo per la scienza tante cose
sono in un modo.
Per cui bisogna attenersi a quelli
che sono i fatti
e non a quello che crediamo noi,
per esempio.
Quello è un grosso problema.
Un grosso problema anche perchè ormai
da decenni si usa tantissimo internet.
Su internet ci può scrivere chiunque
e quindi questo qui aumenta
questa difficoltà.
Pensate se voi andate a cercare su Google
il virus della malaria,
trovate il virus della malaria.
Però la malaria non è un virus.
Se cercate bene
trovate anche dimostrazioni
che la terra è piatta e cose del genere.
Vi assicuro potete trovare veramente
tante cose.
Perchè Google è fatto per confermare
i nostri pregiudizi, i nostri pensieri.
E a noi non piace mai sentirci scemi.
Non ci piace.
Quindi andiamo su internet e cerchiamo
la nostra risposta.
E su internet, vi assicuro la nostra
risposta la troviamo sempre.
Quindi come fare ad esempio
nell'ambito scientifico, salute?
È sicuramente complicato, però ci sono
delle piccole strategie.
Innanzitutto individuare quando ci sono
quelle parole chiave
che vi ho fatto vedere prima.
Quando ci sono queste parole chiave
"din-din-din!" lampadina
attenzione, forse siamo più deboli
in quel momento
e dobbiamo farci attenzione.
Come facciamo a capirlo?
Possiamo affidarci ad altre persone.
Altre persone che siano competenti.
Nel campo della scienza e della salute
non affidiamoci al primo che passa.
Non affidiamoci a chi magari ci vende
qualcosa di nuovo che ci sembra logico.
Perché a volte purtroppo la scienza
funziona in maniera diversa.
Affidiamoci a persone competenti.
Ci sono tanti scienzati o ricercatori
che parlano in maniera corretta
di temi come l'alimentazione, salute
e via dicendo.
Cerchiamo di affidarci a loro.
Ci sono pagine scientifiche
"Le Scienze", "Oggi Scienza",
"Italia unita per la scienza"
ce ne sono tante che potete
consultare,
un po' tipo bigino,
quando si hanno dei dubbi.
Perché tutti noi abbiamo dei dubbi.
Come mai il bicchiere d'acqua?
Non perché voglio che evitiate
di bere l'acqua, anzi, bevetela
che è una cosa che fa bene.
Ma per dirvi: continuate a cercare
a incuriosirvi perché è una cosa
che è bellissima.
Il nostro cervello, il nostro cuore
è giusto che lo facciano
perché è una cosa
che ci da tantissime soddisfazioni.
Facciamo sempre attenzione
a chi diamo la nostra fiducia
e possibilmente cerchiamo di non perderci
in un bicchiere d'acqua.
Grazie.
(Applausi)
(Musica)